how do you feel about James like what is
your what is your relationship with them
my real opinion right your real honest
thing I real opinion about jinx is you
know I'm not the biggest fan I like it
I'm cool with it
I'm not about it though this whole like
react over thing going on this react
tastic for I mean I don't contribute it
into it by talking with you right now
I'm not the I'm not so drawn to being a
big part of it honestly with the way
jinxes personality is it seems best that
he is kind of his own thing doing that I
met jinx in person at VidCon and I
posted a video and people thought it was
real when jinx was like get the [ __ ] out
of here that wasn't real at all Jason
and that's what I mean it's like I
wanted people to think it was real but
it's not know I kicked it with jinx for
about like two to three hours my honest
opinion him in is he's a cool guy like
you can talk with him and you got fun
with him he's got a lot of self
instilled confidence I'll put it that
way it's one of those things where jinx
yeah there's an ego present but his ego
is serving him well it's it's gathering
him success it's gathering him you know
a career he wants and he he has friends
that will with him and they they love
him and I honestly don't think he got
the box if people want it if people want
my real opinion on that I don't think he
got the box I heard about his MCM that
he's partnered with I heard about the
benefit that come with the MCM that he's
partnered with and I was are you
familiar with multi-channel networks
youtubers eventually like partner with a
multi-channel network but I heard about
them I have a friend and partner with
them and they're seeing results that are
crazy so I can see how jinx could have
authentically gotten the subscribers on
top of that too
I don't know I just think jinx what he's
doing his thing and I'm totally cool I
don't really watch this channel but he's
doing this thing people love him and
have VidCon he was getting recognized a
[ __ ] ton I just doubt those bots are
fake because when I was at VidCon I
almost every step we took people were
coming up Sam
hey guys I'm Ryan Wright today I'm here
with I'm Dante people who had asked me
for a QA or some type of interview for a
while now I figured if I ever did that I
would show as much of my genuine real
side as much as possible and I thought
if there's anyone right now who really
deserves to get to know the real me it's
I'm Dante because I've been [ __ ] with
this guy for way too long and I can't
stop [ __ ] with him I want to clear
some things up why I have him here with
me right now
he did the roast of Tyrone Magnus and I
was making fun of him for being mean and
I got a I got a pretty dark sense of
humor sometimes so I was just mean back
because I was like he wasn't that mean
so I'm gonna be extra mean to make up
for the lack of mean business I know it
wasn't exactly witty or anything but I
was just [ __ ] around and then for the
honest trailers one I knew other people
would be reacting to it and I was like
everyone's gonna be laughing and [ __ ]
the girl that was with me all the stock
drama Dante now the girl that was with
me
Noel I told her like I'm gonna wear some
shades because you know you ever see
those like roasts where the celebrities
wear shades to like kind of hide how
they're feeling just to [ __ ] around and
that's what I did no one got the [ __ ]
joke they all thought like Orion's a
[ __ ] right and I don't know well that
that's how it's gonna go down that there
are gonna be people who are gonna hate
what I'm doing but I just figured you
know it's like everyone's doing the same
thing I was just gonna [ __ ] around and
do something a little different and try
to make you feel as uncomfortable as
possible the reason why I Skype so late
I was watching your reaction to the
video and I was like this is exactly
what I wanted I wanted him to feel just
so uncomfortable like I did it just for
you I didn't like it wasn't for the fans
it was like I want to just get a
reaction out of on Dante they're like
okay this is gonna be the same as the
Rose it doesn't look like he's really
[ __ ] with it and yeah thank God but
no man in all sincerity it was hard not
to laugh I was trying to do that
celebrity roasting where you're like
trying to keep a straight face the whole
time and seem like you're not affected
by the words I honestly like I was how
a hard time laughing and the time when I
broke a little bit was when you did the
host of my I'm Dante and you threw a
picture at Chris Tucker and there okay
yeah that [ __ ] got me cuz I was like
yeah I could see that what's awesome is
like I don't know we when'd you start
the channel twenty thirteen uh this
channel yeah I started this channel
earlier this year oh okay cool yeah I
didn't start off my channel doing it
reactions it was movie reviews then what
happened was I saw Gator Mardan do a
reaction I saw several of his and then I
was like cuz Gator Martin's the one who
really started all this well yeah it's
like I know there's the finebros but
doing it solo and really making
something out of it that was gator
martin i saw him do it and i was like
cool this looks like fun i'll just do it
to [ __ ] around this seems easy and i
wasn't expecting it to get any views or
anything like that i was like who the
hell is really gonna watch a reaction
and i did it and it started getting
views and subscribers kept wanting more
and then before I knew it it became the
main driving source of the channel what
I really admire about what you're doing
while you're doing reactions you're
still putting together other stuff to
let it be known that you're more than
reactions like I got plenty of other
[ __ ] on my channel you know there's even
short films and sketches I post once a
month or every other month it's like a
lot of people seem to forget about that
you're developing a reputation up front
that you do more than just reactions
that you could put other videos together
so it's very admirable and it's very
smart to do that too yeah I didn't want
to just be known as a reactor might at
first that's all I was doing and like
same as you
I saw a gator Martin's video and then I
saw videos Tyrone's and that made me
really want to start reacting so I did
that and then I decided you know why not
throw in some movie reviews throwing a
blog here and there and just other
random videos because I was always
saying that people would make a second
channel to do stuff and I was thinking
like why not just do everything on one
channel so it's not all quite crazy like
this yeah yeah for the real rejects you
know like we have a lot of [ __ ] on there
and yeah I saw that you I don't know if
you took my advices remember I sent you
an email after you did the roast
and I was right yeah I immediately went
back and like changed everything like
the most popular and then I added
playlist I was like okay yeah I see how
it works also thank you for that because
my most popular videos are even getting
more views because of that so yeah
thanks for your advices really helped a
lot yeah so you love people don't know
that a lot of people don't know that
after the roast I was like hitting you
up and talking to you so oh like Ryan's
dude yeah Ryan writes a [ __ ] Ryan I
can't take a joke and it just it cracks
me up because I don't know who were some
of your favorite comedians definitely
Kevin Hart Chris Tucker Eddie Murphy the
freakin what's the do Lois case Lois
shaking that's my favorite one my
biggest inspirations in my life have
been louis c.k Conan O'Brien and then
there's actors and [ __ ] of course but as
far as like this entertainment
personality world it's been Louie CK
Conan O'Brien and I remember I watched
the movie or seen the movie men on the
moon about Andy Kaufman well that was my
introduction to Andy Kaufman I loved it
when I was younger cuz it was like this
guy does stupid bits and makes things
look real because it makes him laugh so
right he does [ __ ] to [ __ ] with the
audience so they think he's doing
something real but it's making him laugh
I think okay I can see exactly how that
influenced you yeah totally yeah yeah
that's what I mean it's like I do [ __ ]
just to [ __ ] with audiences sometimes I
like it when they think I'm being real
like I've gotten called racist I've
gotten called sexist I've been told like
I'm a big jerk to my girlfriend and
people think I'm like exhibit jokes I
make like when people started thinking I
make a lot of sex jokes I was like sweet
I'm gonna amplify this and get people to
think I'm really a pervert like only a
few selected people can think that way
you know like I don't know it's just
funny that's like
I like watching your videos and your
channels like if there's a video that
I've already seen and I know like
Brian's reaction would be like crazy and
he'd say some weird stuff I'm going
straight to your channel to see it
because I just know you're gonna say the
craziest thing yeah it's funny because
when I did the roast to the trailer like
that's an example like yeah I did one
reaction where I kept a straight face
for most of it right suddenly I'm
getting all these comments of like Ryan
so boring he never reacts he never does
I'm like thinking I just posted several
videos where I'm like flipping out and
now they're like he never does and he
never shows emotion that I don't know
it's stupid and you know like louis c.k
will say things sometimes just to get a
reaction out of the crowd that that's
that's what I mean I'm definitely
inspired by and my favorite um solo
artist is Eminem I'm too bro really I'm
really inspired by Eminem and I know he
does similar things just to like
generate a reaction so that's pretty
much like my thing and see I just want
it I want to talk to you face-to-face
and be like dude I've just been [ __ ]
around and I really admire your [ __ ] and
you're you're awesome and your channel
is growing so [ __ ] fast and you've
gotten a lot of people mimicking this
roast thing you started so [ __ ] and it's
funny you know like if someone's not
cracking up like if someone's not
reacting to them the way Tyrone is
reacting like cracking up except for the
bad rule that one but it but you know
when he's like cracking up and [ __ ]
people are like this guy is taking [ __ ]
so personal but it's funny because like
it's a roast and every roast
I noticed has one or two people that
crossed the line and I intentionally do
that I don't do it by accident but yeah
dude so like what made you start YouTube
like I said before seeing Gators
reaction and I forgot which the action
video was but I was like that that looks
cool and that seemed Tyrone do it I was
like I gotta I gotta do this so I went
into the garage and a lot of people
wonder
why I do my reactions in my garage and
that's because I have like three sisters
oh wow and yeah they're always like
coming in my room without knocking
without any questions not gonna work so
I just do my reactions in the garage
because I didn't know interruptions
there so yeah it's been my thing ever
since and I remember the first time I
did a reaction in my room people were
like well where's the garage bro like
what are you doing like it's crazy so
you know I'm 22 about to turn 23
September 2nd and I heard you oh you're
a day before my birthday a day before
yeah I'm the third oh yeah so what how
old are you I'm gonna be 25 oh wow I
never reveal my actual age but I told
you for you I'll answer anything but I
never reveal my actual age yeah I'm
gonna be 25 on the 3rd and damn you're
the second why we should hit each other
up where do you live with City Jani
Beach Virginia Beach that is far from
where I am no yeah you should one day
come out to California you like you have
your channels growing fast and like most
of the youtubers are out here did you
write down any questions I actually did
a sweet there's some people on Instagram
that have some questions for you oh yeah
I said it on Instagram if you guys can
ask where I write anything what would it
be I got I got a couple of a lot of
questions so yeah all right cool first
we're gonna start with some of the
questions like that I want to know
personally how long have you and
Veronica been together exactly as of a
few days ago one year exactly one year
but we've known each other for about 11
to 12 years ah yeah I was friendzone for
a very long time I guess you already
answered this but where did you get your
sense of humor from growing up okay
another aspect that was really big my
dad was I mean there's a lot of very
personal things I don't mind sharing
them if you end up asking questions
about it but my dad was when he had a
sense of humor he would he was not like
me in the sense that if I'm crossing the
line or saying things like I know what
I'm doing and I know what I'm saying -
like generate a reaction my dad would
cross the line so much and he had no
idea he was doing that it's kind of have
you ever seen Curb Your Enthusiasm
yeah he's kind of like Larry David in
the sense that he's just so unaware what
he's doing and saying that he's pissing
off people and then he wonders why
people are pissed off I mean he he died
a couple years ago but that's a strong
memory to have of him is I got a crazy
sense of humor from them because my dad
had a lot of pain in his life and I
don't know what your background is but I
grew up with like I'm diagnosed with I
have three main diagnoses I was
diagnosed a couple years ago with PTSD
and I'm diagnosed with ADHD and type 2
bipolar so I've been in therapy for
about like four to five years now and
it's awesome I love therapy the thing
about it was I noticed that the
comedian's that have a lot of painful up
brains him laugh at a lot more things
than the average person you know I feel
I feel the exact same way my dad I don't
know who he is I don't know what so
that's how that is I have a stepdad and
like when I was younger is a lot of
things happen
I wasn't treated the way like instead
that should treat the child so yeah
there's a lot of stuff going on there
but like you said about comedian thing
they go through a lot and that's why
they can laugh at a lot of things yeah
exactly yeah it sounds like you know
what it's really like to experience some
serious trauma you know like it sounds
like your dad abandoning you and it
sounds like your stepdad is pretty
[ __ ] abusive and I know what it's
like to grow up with a [ __ ] ton of abuse
too like my therapist has said my home
is technically domestic violence when I
was growing up so I know what it's like
to grow up with a lot of abuse to that's
why it's like I could kind of pick up on
that like when I did my mean roast to
you the way you did a skit together
showing that you can laugh about
something pretty dark